So how much money I have on paper
has never had such a
big impact on my life, okay, but it has
changed my life in the sense that,
from my point of view, the pressure is higher
when you're public, yes, and it puts a
strain on me knowing that people
believed in us, believed in me,
bought the shares and then
now, at least on paper, they
are somehow negative or maybe
the light - if you
sold the shares then that's
what that puts a huge strain on me I took
precautions Julia  I also never worked with outside
capital, again with
bank capital nor with investor
capital. There were very small exceptions where
I took my investors in,
but always only a very small
amount because I always knew that it was a
burden for me to accept the real money from others